please welcome oscar-winning daredevil
and athletic
of the five original screenplays
nominated this year some were written in
a burst of creative energy and others
were gestating for periods of up to 30
years and here are the nominees for
original screenplay
Todd Haynes for far from heaven
Jay Cox Steve Zaillian and Kenneth
Lonergan four Gangs of New York
Nia Vardalos for My Big Fat Greek
Wedding Pedro almodóvar for talked to
her
Carlos cuarón and Alfonso Cuaron for e
tu mama tambien and the Oscar goes to
Pedro almodóvar for talk to her
this is the first Oscar for Pedro
almodóvar including his nomination
tonight for directing this is his second
Academy
oh I know that to breathe is very
expensive tonight but I have to breathe
a well first of all thank you to the
members of the Academy for their
generosity this is I mean I don't know
this is really too much
and I would like to read something now
is prohibited but it will be very short
you know of course I dedicate this to
all the sale to Sony Pictures classic
and all and all the people that helped
me to make this movie but I also want to
dedicate this word to other people that
are raising their voices in favour of
peace respect of human rights democracy
and international leg elite legality all
of which are essential qualities to live
this award is also to then add to the
spanish cinema and to all you because
you are the witness of this wonderful
moment of my life
time's up I'm sorry